نبقى في تونس حيث قال الرئيس قيس سعيد ان
اتحاد الشغل حر في تنظيم مظاهراته لكنه
ليس حرا في دعوه الاجانب للمشاركه فيها
مشيرا الى ان ذلك غير مقبول باي مقياس من
المقاييس على حد تعبير
ولكن من يريد ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
لتكن معاملتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستاما او ارضا
بلا سيد
وسدد الرئيس التونسي في لقاء جمعه بوزير
الشؤون الاجتماعيه مالك الزاهي على محاسبه
من وصفهم بالاعداء ممن يتربصون بالشعب
التونسي وفق تعبيره
هو اليوم انا اوان المحاسبه ولا تراجعه عن
هذه المحاسبه اطلاقا
لانها مطلب مشروع للشعب التونسي
وهناك اليوم للاسف
من يتحالف مع هؤلاء الذين
ارادوا الافلات من المحاسبه ومن المساءله
ولكن هذا عهد قطع له على انفسنا في ان لا
يذهب اي مليم الا للشعب التونسي